[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
pour le sommaire de votre magazine
football versailles promu cette saison
en nationale 3 réussi à tenir en échec
le leader invaincu créteil lusitanos à
domicile
score final un but partout le résumé du
match et a su dans quelques instants tu
boxes un grand gala sera organisé le
bronze novembre au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
les boxeurs d'euractiv farrugia marvin
petit galice coulon seront sur le ring
pour des matches de classement
nous les recevrons dans quelques
instants sur le plateau avec leur
entraîneur temps guy farrugia
cyclisme le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
également le quatrième grand prix de
bellignies sur sa piste ce dimanche une
épreuve qui comptera pour la première
manche de la coupe ile de france plus
d'informations à suivre avec l'un des
organisateurs à michel barraud on
commence tout de suite ce magazine par
l'actualité sportive de la semaine
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
football direction les terrains de
national troyes la 5e division française
versailles en difficulté depuis le début
de la saison avec seulement deux
victoires au compteur recevez l'un des
prétendants à la montée à créteil
lusitanos
le match s'est soldé par un très bon
match nul pour les versaillais
le résumé du match les images sont
signés à nicolas d'ambri rencontre
capitale ce samedi 28 octobre pour
versailles les joueurs de la cité royale
en blanc recevait le leader invaincu
créteil lusitanos
après une entame de match poussive les
versets et qui restait sur deux
victoires consécutives ont réussi à
marquer dès la 20e minute de jeu
ils ont ensuite maîtrisé la fin de la
première période grâce à une tactique
établie avant le match et continuer de
consignes donc continuer à bien
travailler ensemble a bien bossé dans le
bloc réduire les espaces avoir une
fonction quand on n'a pas la balle une
zone à respecter d'aidé coulissement
respecter des couvertures qui ensuite
contenant le ballon bain bien analysées
pour savoir si on peut se projeter ou
bien préparer encore et avec une qualité
technique à chaque instant au retour des
vestiaires versailles baisse de rythme
créteil lusitanos est proche d'égaliser
sur penalty mais c'est finalement 15
minutes du coup de sifflet final que la
défense versaillaise se fait surprendre
sur une erreur malheureusement une
situation qui nous pend dix équipes
ayant qu'on paye cher donc et camille
nuisent un peu tout le travail qui a été
réalisé depuis le début du match pour ça
que des joueurs qui s'entraînent
régulièrement matin après midi et soir
donc ils ont peut-être plus de jeux de
jus dans les jambes
après je pense qu'ils ont aussi monté
d'intensité on a vu par l'entraîneur je
pense qu'il a aussi aussi haussé le ton
je pense en vont à la mi temps donc on a
senti une petite différence mais je
pense que c'est aussi dû à un petit peu
de la fatigue groupé avec le gros
travail qu'on a fourni en première mi
temps malgré un carton rouge pour
créteil lusitanos dans les dernières
minutes de la rencontre le score
n'évoluera plus un but partout score
final content et pas comprendre ou par
rapport à
par rapport au résumé du match bon après
voilà c'est ça le football
voilà on aurait préféré gagner surtout
qu'on est à domicile et voilà c'est
comme ça quand je travaillais tout au
long de la saison
avec ce résultat versailles remonte au
classement et occupe désormais la 10e
place à six points du podium prochain
match ce dimanche 5 novembre contre les
us toujours à domicile du football
encore avec le championnat r4 trappe se
déplacer ce week-end sur le terrain de
l'équipe de boulogne billancourt pour le
compte de la 6e journée et les
trappistes sont repartis avec une
défaite dans leurs valises
ils se sont inclinés 2 à 1 aux
classements trappe fait du surplace les
hommes d'arno est mise il reste à la
sixième place du championnat avec un
bilan de 3 victoires et 3 défaites
depuis septembre dernier du football
encore et toujours direction les
terrains de 2e division de district en
match en retard plaisir est allé
s'imposer sur le terrain de bougival 4
buts à 2 une cinquième victoire en six
matches disputés cette saison qui permet
aux fo plaisir wa de remonter à la
deuxième place du classement et de
revenir à hauteur du leader monter son
prochain match dimanche prochain à 15
heures sur le terrain de vélizy à 78 en
rugby à plaisir jouer ce week-end son 6e
match de fédérale 2 contre rennes l'une
des meilleures équipes du championnat
pas de surprise pour le promu évinois
plaisir s'incline 36 à 0 contre son
adversaire du jour
une cinquième défaite en six matches qui
ne fait pas les affaires des plaisirs
oies au classement il reste 10e à
égalité de points avec l'avant-dernier
arras prochain match dimanche prochain
contre gennevilliers 7e du championnat
on continue par du cyclisme sur piste
nous en parlions à la semaine dernière
l'équipe de france a réalisé une superbe
performance pendant les derniers
championnats d'europe qui se sont
déroulés à berlin avec 8 médailles d'or
8 médailles dont cinq en or
parmi les satisfactions quentin lafargue
le saint quentinois remporté une
médaille de bronze sur le kilomètre et
surtout la médaille d'or en vitesse par
équipes on écoute quentin lafargue tout
juste revenu de la compétition qui était
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
on est au niveau des des meilleurs
résultats mondiaux de la saison dernière
sans pour autant comparer parce que tout
est difficile de comparer d'année en
année etc
mais voilà non
on bat le record petit à petit et c'est
ce qui ce qui est très très encourageant
pour la suite
chez les féminines une seule médaille
été récoltés pendant ces championnats
d'europe à berlin c'est la jeune
mathilde de gros la pépite du sprint
français qui a remporté la médaille
d'argent en vitesse individuelle face à
l'allemande kristina vos gueules
une belle performance qui selon elle va
lui permettre de grandir et
d'emmagasiner de l'expérience on écoute
mathilde de gros globalement c'est
positif après je regarde toujours les
points négatifs pour pouvoir les
améliorer du coup là on a vu tous les
points
mauvais on va dire technique pour
essayer de mieux faire
au prochaine coupe du monde l'a déjà le
fait de courir déjà en quarts de finale
contre des filles où il ya que même pas
deux dixièmes d'écart
les matchs sont beaucoup plus serrées et
là le physique ça va plus fin ça suffit
plus il faut savoir bien courir et là
j'étais obligé de savoir bien courir
du coup j'ai pris énormément en
expérience et j'espère en pas enfin
apprendre encore plus sur les coupes du
monde qui arrive nous allons à présent
parler de boxe dos aux 7,8 sport et plus
précisément de la team farrugia le 11
novembre prochain un grand gala de boxe
organisé dans l'air central du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
les boxeurs locaux seront très bien
représentée pour combattre dans
l'enceinte sportive on retrouvera
notamment trois boxeurs de la team
farrugia marine petit gallus coulon et
marina tollé qu'ils combattront pour des
matches de classement
deux boxeurs trois boxeurs qui sont avec
nous en plateau avec leur coach ce temps
guy farrugia
bonsoir alors tant guy farrugia on
l'attendait depuis de nombreuses années
ce combat au vélodrome ce grand gala au
vélodrome ça y est c'est enfin dans
l'agenda
enfin pendant les deux dates qu'on
attendait mais bon de là marvin vous
l'attendiez aussi vous ce grand gala de
boxe
oui je l'attendais aussi ça fait déjà un
moment que j'attends il arrive est il
arrivé plus tôt que prévu trois semaines
j'ai su trois semaines avant ce mois
donc on accepte ainsi au vélodrome c'est
ça le fait qu'à lui c'est un sale fait
vraiment pour la boxe sur vous c'est une
très très belle salle le vélodrome c'est
le plus grand d'europe donc vraiment ça
fait vraiment plaisir de boxer dans d'un
tel endroit donc maintenant ça fait déjà
quatre cinq ans quand on se disait qu'on
va organiser on organise son organisme
et finalement ça se faisait pas donc là
maintenant c'est vraiment
une fin en soi et une attente qu'on
l'attendait vraiment depuis très
longtemps
qu'est-ce que ça va changer concrètement
pour vous moi actuellement je suis dans
le top 10 français
dans ma catégorie super léger donc là
c'est vraiment combattre classement
permettent d'engranger une ou deux
places pour prétendre j'espère en 2018
effectué en championnat de france
donc vous allez combattre contre le
français tarek d'air fouchy c'est ça son
bilan va être quatre victoires deux
défaites et un nul
c'est un adversaire votre portée tout à
fait ainsi un adversaire comme vigie
toujours sanaa vers 5h braga qui a boxé
beaucoup d'étrangers donc maintenant
les adversaires ont une valeur qui je
suis ce que je ne pourrais pas dire
forcément deux boxeurs français donc
maintenant aujourd'hui un boxeur
français j'ai les moyens pour sortir
vainqueur de ce combat et
comme je dis toujours il a c'est un
homme et du bras des jambes comme moi
donc maintenant c'est à moi de travers
le travail pour sortir vainqueur tanguy
gallus a plus d'expérience que son
adversaire il a déjà sept victoires à
son actif
ça permettrait d'avoir un bilan
équilibré en sachant qu'il a huit
défaites pour l'instant galice où il a
plus d'expérience en boxe pro les pende
observateurs parce qu'il avait un paquet
de gomme amateurs donc maintenant je
pense que oui les gars lucile et je
pense qu'il est vraiment au dessus de
son enfin vraiment eu je pense qu'il va
faire ce qu'il faut pour être au dessus
de son adversaire
marvin vous le sentez à prêt à relever
ce défi gallus oui les joueurs à
l'entraînement et j'ai toujours aimé en
fait gagner c'est tout tout est dans sa
tête en fait je lui dis toujours prêt
physiquement il est toujours prêt et
même sur le ring fait des mises de gants
ensemble et il est dur quoi il est
toujours là donc là je pense qu'il est
prêt maintenant c'est à lui de se
déclencher dans sa tête de dire voilà je
vous l'avais tour alors de votre côté
vous marvin vous êtes trop être opposé à
un géorgien georgi abraham ich liebe
suis dit c'est ça si je me trompe pas
ces 19 victoires dont 9 par ko 14
défaites et un nul
il a 23 ans il est un peu plus jeune que
vous mais comment vous vous
l'appréhendez vous ce combat je
l'appréhendais comme un match comme
comme à l'autre quoi c'est un prêt voilà
c'est là c'est mon retour depuis depuis
les depuis l'été est bon je suis prêt
physiquement ça à six roues là
physiquement je suis prêt pour ainsi
rouge et en a prévenu trois semaines en
avance donc voila apres c au vélodrome
j'ai pas voulu le
j'ai pas voulu dire non on va boucher
quoi on travaille c'est un petit peu
dommage qu'on prévienne marvin dernière
seconde pour ce type de combat tout le
monde est-ce que c'est dommage qu'on
prévienne tout c'est dommage
en début de saison disons qu'en début de
saison peut-être en mars avril où on
repense comme tout le monde après les
vacances d'été
on reprend là c'est fait deux mois après
la reprise finalement donc de trois mois
après la reprise
c'est toujours un tu peux juste je pense
qu'on est en phase de remise en forme 10
on sort a été en mars avril soit
peut-être pas été le même le même topo
maintenant connaissant les deux
gaillards je vais voix ils sont font
toujours ce qu'il faut pour être prêt
lors de leur combat donc
donc il ya pas de soucis pour ça pour
marvin tanguy le difficulté ce sera
peut-être de prendre le combat la légère
enfin oui ça il faut jamais sous-estimer
qui que ce soit mais je pense pas qu'ils
sous-estiment n'aura la difficulté c'est
qu'il bosse pas dans sa catégorie peau
je pense que c'est juste ça voilà c'est
pour ça qu'on n'a pas voilà voilà soins
des fils et c'est pas une chèvre non
plus j'en sais pas quelqu'un qui vient
se coucher c'est quelqu'un qui est bien
pour gagner
donc maintenant il faudra qu en montant
la différence le marvin dames niveau
européen pas l'autre marvin vous ne
prenez pas comme un entraînement du tout
ce combat en sachant que vous êtes
détenteur d'une ceinture européenne
ça sera qu'un match de classement c'est
ce qu'il ya un risque peut-être de se
laisser déconcentrer finalement dans non
je vais pas me déconcentrer
jean le combat je vais je rester sérieux
parce qu'on
un combat comme un autre c'est même la
pire en pire la perche eve peux te
mettre un teint un coup et c'est fini
quoi mais voilà vous avez qui était
largement au dessus de son adversaire
qui a gagné tous les room et à un moment
la bce demain baril après un crochet il
ya plus vous sentez que marvin il a
évolué dans sa boxe sur les derniers
combats avant il cherchait énormément de
chaos
finalement aujourd'hui il gère plus si
ça maintenant il cherche vraiment à
construire son combat sans chercher le
coup dur parce que maintenant tout le
monde sait que marvin c'est un trappeur
donc les adversaires maintenant il lève
les mains et ils font plus attention
dans le sens où ils savent qu'à tout
moment sur un coup ça peut se terminer
donc
lui aussi il a pris conscience de ça et
les services est vraiment maintenant de
développer sa box sans chercher le coup
dur marine vous vous allez combattre
pour la première fois en professionnel
lors de ce grand gala comment
appréhendez-vous ce combat comment j'ai
fait donc c'était en occitanie
avec anxiété non je n'étais pas stress
je suis pas quelqu'un de stressé par
nature on verra le jour j mais j'ai pas
quelqu'un de stressé par nature avec
beaucoup
disons un peu d'inconnus un peu de
nouveauté un peu voilà c'est on sort de
ce que je connais chez les filles ça
fait particulièrement une grande
différence parce que maintenant en
amateur chez les gays il ya plus de
casques etc
chez les filles ya toujours des casques
ça reste des gars et des bandages
maintenance et du bondage durs cd gants
plus petits
donc voilà c'est tout un tas de choses
nouvelles qui fait que ce combat c'est
une grande nouveauté
un défi où on définit toute façon c'est
comme je disais ce cette entame en boxe
professionnelle
c'est pour pas avoir de regrets c'est
pour pas avoir de regret c'est que il
est temps c'était maintenant ou jamais
si je voulais entamé ma carrière
professionnelle
donc voilà j'en ai en plus à domicile
c'était pas du tout prévue jeudi à plein
temps de marvin le combat mon premier
combat aurait dû être un petit peu plus
tard et dans un autre contexte
voilà je pense que maintenant tanguy a
su saisir l'opportunité camp nou là nous
la présenter donc à moi de faire mes
preuves dernière question
marvin il faudra peut-être pas trop
s'enflammer devant ce public du
vélodrome en sachant que vous êtes à
domicile fera peut-être géré son combat
encore plus après mon nom là je sais
j'ai 23 combats je sais maintenant que
je sais comment gérer mes combats après
voilà le public il est là et je vais pas
regarder le public j'ai regardé mon
combat de me dire voilà de travailler
parce que en fait je suis un travailleur
sonnerie j'aime j'aime travailler sur le
rien au fait vous voulez voir des
boxeurs concentrer sur le ring faire
abstraction de la foule attendue dans la
foulée pas là pour ces pages il faut
donc c'est clair la foulée il faut il
faut un public
on aime le public on aime les gens qui
aiment la boxe la vraie boxe
maintenant il faut aussi le sportif il
est pas là pour faire un spectacle
il est là pour donner le meilleur de soi
même et pas pour faire le plein merci à
tous les cas d'être venu sur ce plateau
on vous souhaite d'assurer le spectacle
au vélodrome la semaine saint quentin en
yvelines
le 11 novembre prochain et les résultats
seront évidemment annoncée dans un
prochain à 7,8 sport nous allons à
présent ranger les gants pour prendre la
direction des greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines coup de
projecteur aujourd'hui sur alexandra
bonetti la sportive qui s'entraînent
entre saint germain en laye et
guyancourt est à 25 ans l'une des plus
grandes golfeuses française de sa
génération
son portrait le montage est signé avec
des vigiles
[Musique]
alexandra bonetti et joueuses
professionnelles sur le circuit européen
mais avant d'en faire son métier le golf
est avant tout une passion pour cette
parisienne de 25 ans la sportive à taper
ses premières balles à l'âge de 7 ans au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines après avoir vu ses parents
joués décidé à s'améliorer elle a
ensuite pris des cours dans la structure
sous l'impulsion de sa famille
on a donc dû commencer à prendre des
leçons vers l'âge de 10 ans il avait une
super école de golf ici vraiment
vraiment super donc je suis resté
jusqu'à mes 17 ans et un tous les
week-ends il m'amenait
le mercredi après midi il m'amenait
après l'école ils ont - ils ont tout
fait pour que je puisse réussir dans ce
que j'aime cette passion à développer
son esprit de compétition 2007 à saint
quentin en yvelines à golfeuses décroche
à 15 ans la médaille de bronze du
championnat d'europe dames en étant
invité du tournoi un moment clé dans sa
jeune carrière presque impensable
je me suis dit c'est vraiment
suite à cette performance alexandra
bonetti intègre l'équipe de france
termine 3e des championnats du monde
amateurs en argentine en 2010 et rafle
l'or au championnat d'europe dames en
après son bac elle joue dans une
université au texas entre 2011 et 2015
et sillonne les greens américain pour
continuer à engranger les succès sur le
circuit la joueuse s'entraîne de façon
intense six jours sur sept
donc il ya cinq séances de sport par
semaine que je fais soit le matin avant
de venir au goal soit dans la soirée et
ensuite c'est un
un équilibre entre le practice le petit
jeu donc petit shipping et le parcours
donc ça s'apprend pas mal de temps un
entraînement nécessaires pour réaliser
une quinzaine de tournois par an aux
quatre coins du monde et surtout pour
perfectionner son point fort le jeu
court pour cela alexandra a mis en place
une technique
je vais prendre beaucoup de recul
derrière la bad pour regarder une
première fois la ligne surtout les
gauches droites
puis je vais aller de l'autre côté là je
vais aller un peu moins loin pour
surtout centrée sur la fin du pote et
les mouvements à près du trou et ensuite
je vais repasser par le côté le plus bas
cette technique sur le jeu court lui
permettra peut-être de réussir à
intégrer le circuit américain dame à
l'horizon 2019
l'un de ses plus grands rêves de
golfeuses à bientôt
on prend maintenant la direction de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines le club de voile organisé ce
week-end une régate de verser des
bateaux miniatures à voile
radiocommandée 13 participants s'étaient
inscrits pour cette compétition
officielle de grade 3 qui permettait de
collecter à 500 points
notre journaliste nicolas dendrite est
sur place pour rencontrer ces mordus de
voile télécommandé
une compétition de voile un peu spéciale
ce dimanche 29 octobre sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
le navigateur n'est pas sur l'eau mais
bien sur la terre ferme 13 participants
se sont inscrits pour cette course
versée parmi eux johan poulain 45 ans ce
passionné venu spécialement de vendée
pour participer à cette journée
personnellement je prends du plaisir à
naviguer et puis aussi à les préparer
les bateaux allaient construire au moins
40% du plaisir c'est fabriqué développer
de l'améliorer sur ce plan d'eau il
présente sa toute nouvelle formule 1 des
mers le bateau mesure entre 127 et 129
cm de long avec un demi mètre carrés de
voile celui ci donc je les ai fabriqués
en début mars salle de cette année donc
c'est tout en carbone uniquement du
carbone et donc c'est fabriqué mai
dans un moule donc l on applique du
tissu de la résine ont fait cuire tout
ça on fait cuire tout ça soixante 60 70
degrés pour être assez technique
aujourd'hui la compétition fait partie
du 3ème grade nationale après les
championnats de france et le championnat
régional 500 points était en jeu et un
arbitre officiel était présent pour la
régate pour remporter la victoire et
yoann à sa stratégie comme les skippers
professionnels aujourd'hui un vent qui
peut être assez fluctuant donc
heureusement des fois ça
la porte s'ouvre pas où se refermer faut
c'est d'être réactif vous regardez faut
pas regarder que son bateau faut
regarder beaucoup les autres pour pas
faire d'erreurs de placement
et puis aussi regarder un petit peu de
mes surfaces durant la surface de la mer
des ferries et cisailles voit une
nouvelle compétition de verser sera
organisée l'année prochaine sur les
rives de l'ill de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
pour patienter jusque là les vagues de
la structure accueilleront les
championnats de flotte laser le 11
novembre prochain
mais cette fois ci en taille réelle on
passe maintenant l'intro pages agenda on
ouvre cette page agenda part du cyclisme
ce week-end le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera la
quatrième édition du grand prix de
vélizy plus de 150 coureurs dont une
vingtaine de féminines sont attendus
pour participer à cet événement pour lui
parler de ce rendez-vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau michel barraud l'un des
co organisateurs de cette compétition
bonsoir bonsoir
alors je le disais c'est la quatrième
édition est ce qu'il y aura changement
tout simplement par rapport aux trois
éditions précédentes où vous gardez une
recette qui fonctionne alors un petit
peu de changements aussi parce que
depuis depuis maintenant l'année
dernière on se cette épreuve fait partie
de la coupe d'île de france
donc on est on organise avec quatre cinq
clubs d'île de france
plusieurs épreuves sur plusieurs mois et
donc donc on fait partie de ce challenge
un petit peu cette coupe d'ile-de-france
donc une première pour le grand prix de
malaisie
c'est la deuxième fois c'est le deuxième
fois qu'on le fait et puis et puis dans
les épreuves un petit peu de nouveautés
aussi puisqu'on va on va on va inclure
des épreuves de type vitesse par équipes
ou kirin est là c'est un petit peu c'est
plus spectaculaire et très sympathique
justement quand il pensait la
programmation pense au public on pense
aux coureurs on pense aux deux eaux de
essentiellement aux coureurs en
particulier puisque effectivement on
essaye de d'avoir le de couvrir le
maximum d'eux
deux coureurs on a des spécialistes de
la vitesse des spécialistes du keirin
des spécialistes des courses d'endurance
donc on essaye de d'élargir notre notre
notre notre part notre plateau mais
d'autres
notre programmation pour pour arriver à
satisfaire tout le monde
et puis aussi m on pense au public parce
que mettre des épreuves spectaculaires
comme le karine par exemple le public
adore c'est très très très très
spectaculaire et ça demande beaucoup de
préparation au niveau de l'organisation
oui oui oui il ya ces décès
et ça commence de nombreux mois avant
avant le démarrage de l'épreuve
effectivement il ya l'organisation avec
le vélodrome avec la société vélopolis
avec nos partenaires donc donc il ya
beaucoup de boulot en amont
je le disais il y aura 150 coureurs dont
une vingtaine de féminines c'est le
seuil qu'on ne pourra pas dépasser pour
le grand prix de vision on peut toujours
attiré plus de coureurs sont en
compétition peut toujours maintenant
maintenant il ya quand même des règles
de sécurité qui nous imposent de pas
trop de coureurs à la fois et comme on
veut nous
faire sur plusieurs catégories donc on
limite on limite le nombre de coureurs
par catégorie et voilà ce qui fait un ce
qui fait un plateau de 150 qui est déjà
à ce qui est déjà très bien pour une
compétition sur piste il y aura la tête
d'affiche sens au rendez vous il y aura
des têtes d'affiché des têtes d'affiché
peut-être pas connu du brand ou du grand
public mais nous avons nous aurons en
vitesse par équipes
nos champions d'europe master en titre
une équipe de vélizy en plus que dès que
des coureurs de vélizy il rentre juste
de los angeles où ils viennent de faire
deuxième aux championnats du monde
masters donc donc une très très forte
équipe
et puis chez les féminines on aura aussi
la participation de deux d'une fille de
l'équipe de france ce piste un
mélissandre pain qui était récemment
médaillé aux championnats d'europe aussi
l'élite
voilà donc et puis en y aura du beau
monde
en juniors juniors on s'attend
normalement avoir ryan et la halle qui
est le champion du monde junior merci
beaucoup avait passé sur ce plateau bon
courage pour l'organisation de cet
événement je le rappelle la compétition
est programmé à ce dimanche de 12h30 à
18h sur la piste du vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines
on continue par du handball féminin
laisse montigny-le-bretonneux reçoit ce
samedi à 20h30 au complexe sportif
pierre de coubertin l'équipe de chambre
et touraine ne rencontre qui comptera
pour la 5e journée du championnat de
nationale 2 victoire obligatoire pour
les inhumant ten qui sont à l'heure
actuelle dernière dieu nationale une
avec seulement un match nul en cinq
rencontres disputées
on écoute l'une des joueuses de l'équipe
à virginie à correa on a très bien
travaillé ça fait deux semaines qu'on a
un nouveau projet de jeu jusque là le
projet de jeu qui était auparavant ne
nous correspondait pas nouveau projet de
jeu avec un peu plus de tactique pour
pouvoir lancer nos arrières puisque la
nouvelle tour de contrôle et à et
beaucoup de gens mouvement je pense que
c'est ça qui nous manquait puisqu'on est
nouvelle équipe
on est trois nouvelles arrivées donc
c'est un peu compliqué il faut que la
mayonnaise prenne toujours handball mais
cette fois ci à chez les garçons en
nationale 3 plaisir reçoit ce dimanche à
16h stella sport à l'occasion de la 5e
journée du championnat les plaisirs wa
promu cette saison dans la division
partiront favoris de la rencontre ils
sont 5e alors que leurs adversaires
pointent à la 9e place en ce début de
championnat la victoire permettrait
rapprocher encore un peu plus plaisir du
maintien de l'objectif fixé en début de
saison on referme ce magazine par de la
voile le départ de la 13e édition de la
transat jacques vabre sera donné ce
dimanche 5 novembre à 13h55 depuis le
port du havre 39 bateaux sont en lice
cette année pour tenter d'arriver au
brésil parmi les skippers on retrouve
deux illinois le versailles et attendit
de la mode sur l'initiative querelles
rambolitains louis burton sur bureau
vallée et ne partiront pas seuls les
deux navigateurs embarqueront chacun
avec une coéquipière tanguy partir avec
la navigatrice samantha davies warburton
de son côté naviguera avec sa femme la
skippeuse servane escoffier
au niveau des objectifs ils joueront
tous les deux la gagne avec des bateaux
équipés de foils talent et est taillé
pour terminer dans le top 3 vont-ils
parvenir à remplir sa performance
réponse aux alentours du 20 novembre
prochain
c'est la fin de cette émission à merci
de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée sur
tv à 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]